the only way for humankind to survive
global extinction is to spread our genes
to more than one planet we have no
choice it's a law of evolution geology
and physics the alternative is death and
extinction we'll have to build a giant
spacecraft capable of crossing
interstellar space and colonizing
distant worlds around other stars you
will essentially need a new Noah's Ark
but it's going to be a space Ark and it
has to encapsulate all of the diversity
of earth inside this one ship
the space Ark will have to be huge big
enough to house the thousands of people
needed to create a healthy gene pool
new planets
too massive to construct on earth the
giant craft will have to be built in
space far from the pool Earth's gravity
but building a shipyard in the sky is no
small challenge
NASA is tackling it
making sense
I see the SLS as a capability that's
going to allow us to put an industrial
base between the earth and the moon
after we do that and we're out there
routinely working in space that's when
we'll assemble the craft that'll take us
to the stars les Johnson's job is to
plan the future of space exploration
today he's observing a test firing rate
of a 1 to 20 scale model SLS
the most powerful rocket ever launched
the SLS is big it's going to give us a
capability to take lots of stuff up with
each launch and it can be big volume and
you could potentially launch three of
these big rockets versus perhaps 15 or
20 of the other rockets we have
available today to get the same amount
of material out into space
les envisions SLS rockets taking
prefabricated units behind where Space
Center's assemble into a colossal
industrial workshop
miners will then fly out to different
bodies of the solar system to collect
the ball materials
we'll have factories in the pool
perhaps even beyond that on giant rocks
inside
asteroids have a fraction Earth's crap
here it will be much easier to build
massive sections
as it begins to take shape
the inner solar system will provide all
we need to make the chores but there's
something missing
in a distant world
will require a propulsion system faster
than anything
you